and you're in uh was it australia or new
zealand if i remember
new zealand got it okay and what's the
dating marketplace like there for you
like what's your experience been so far
pretty bad so what's about give me a
you know give me an example of your last
date or your last relationship that made
it better
my last relationship oh he was a
feminist oh
okay how did you like dating a male
feminist
not great at all why do you think he was
why do you think he was a male feminist
like did he think
it was it was going to win him points
with women or get him to score or
something
i don't know i think i think he had very
low self-esteem
okay yeah okay so he was a male feminist
he didn't like that so
what was it that you didn't like about
that
um well for one thing i was
smarter than him uh he was very
unassertive
and um
yeah the opposite of assertive
and a lot of guys here are like that so
shocking do you like masculinity and
strong men that are decisive
and don't take crap yep
what do i keep telling you guys okay so
how do you find a guy like that i mean
you got to put yourself in a in
in places and positions where guys like
that will
um of course uh get your attention
and you'll get theirs i mean more
specifically like the thing you got to
understand about
about men when it comes to attraction is
we don't care about your degree
and we don't care about how smart you
are we don't care about your pot of gold
because women don't share the pot of
gold with men anyway
um you will get some beta ties males or
some feminized type males that
that will believe narratives that don't
hold true like you just experienced in
your last relationship like you know
the feminist boy but what men care about
is uh beauty cues you know like men are
looked as
success objects by women women are
beauty objects sex objects by men you
follow me
so what you need to do which is going to
be unconventional probably to what
you've been told which is go get a
degree
you can do it all by yourself girl you
know you don't need no man you know have
that backup plan blah blah blah but
in your email if i remember correctly
you said something about wanting to have
a family and be a mother
yeah so what do you think men look for
when it comes to like wife stock
um
i mean you're talking about finding a
high-value masculine strong virtuous man
so
i mean my question you know specifically
to you is what do you think men look for
you know in that kind of woman for
lifestyle if they want to have kids
well yeah like femininity caring um
taking care of just
the more domestic tasks okay so domestic
tasks
so what other values you have to bring
to the table
um caring about what he cares about
in terms of like career goals and doing
something that will help
sounds like you're trying to say support
his purpose
yeah okay um what agent rage do you
do you normally date it
um i'm currently not dating because i do
too much too many things
okay well i mean you're gonna have a
hard time finding a guy to wipe you up
if you're not dating right but i mean
when you are dating what age ranges
usually look at
ideally late late 20s late 20s like what
27 28 yeah
so tuscan razorbacks uh picked up on it
he's he's been watching the channel for
a while
she needs to date older males um
you're 21 right yeah
and you got your party years out of the
way already
i hope so well yeah i don't party much
at all okay
and would you help on you know settling
down and getting married and having kids
like what's the plan for that
uh in the next five years ideally
okay so you're going to be 26 you're
going to be coming up on the epiphany
phase which if you watch my channel you
know that's when women start going
kind of running out of time i got to
find a guy but if you've also been
watching my channel and guys have been
watching me or
reading my book they also know that you
need to wait a couple years to really
you know see what she's all about right
let's test the relationship
let's you know see how she deals with
stress you know what happens when we
travel and the baggage gets lost like
you know does she lose her mind or is
everything cool sort of thing
so you're talking 26 add two more years
you're 28
okay that's fine that's that's a pretty
reasonable strategy i mean you're taking
a logical approach to it but
the thing that you've got to look
towards is if you want that
high-value masculine guy that's not a
feminist
that's strong that's going to lead the
family that's going to be okay with you
staying home raising kids
you're going to have to dial in the
beauty queues because that's because
that's all that guys really want they
want to have a beautiful woman
by their side that's on their purpose
like they want the ride or die girl
basically
at the end of the day right
are you that girl
oh i would like to be so you're not that
girl so
what's stopping you from being that girl
i care a lot about
um my studies and work
as well okay is that is that because of
culture
partly yeah i i want to care about
everything so that's that's what's in my
way right now
okay but that's in conflict with what
the high value guy is that you're
looking for yeah and what would wanting
to have a family
right so how do you reconcile that do
you want to go chase the degree like
what are you going to school for right
now
um to have a good job okay so you don't
want to get into
what field you're getting into but to
have a good job means what like how much
does that pay
um yeah an enjoyable job so
above average salary so so what's above
average like what's the range for you
100 000 a year 150 75
like 80 so that's oh that's more like
60 usd i guess okay
so okay so i mean like you basically
need to find a guy that's making
at least 25 more than that if you're
gonna be fully satisfied
and even that like is that enough to
raise a family where you live
like is i mean if you meet a guy that's
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
okay how many kids you want to have two
or three
okay so if you want two or three kids
where you live what kind of salary does
he need to earn to cover the cost of the
house so you don't have three kids piled
up in one bedroom so they got their own
bedrooms
a yard so they can run around in it yeah
i guess enough income so that mom can
stay home and raise the kids like you
want to do right
yep so how this begins 100 150
200 250.
i think yeah around 100 200. okay
so you're looking for a guy that makes
200 000
a year that's gotta [ __ ] together that's
gonna lead the family
that's smarter than you because you're
finding that you're dating guys that are
not as smart as you and that turns you
off which is totally fine
um you've you've got you've got a big
ask here right
yeah right are you the kind of woman
that a
guy that makes 200 000 a year is going
to want to wife up
i would like to be so you're not so
that's not at the moment right so you're
focusing on
you're focusing on study school and all
that stuff because that's what women
have been told and that's fine i get it
okay
go get your degree you've got the backup
plan in case
things don't work out fine i understand
but
at the end of the day the guy that
you're looking for is looking for
beauty that's going to complement his
life not be the focus of it
you know basically comply with what he's
saying and guys like that are spoiled
for choice right like these are the top
10 of men out there and
you like every other woman out there
right now is competing for that guy
there's there's there's millions of
other women right now in your country
that are
in the school system that are around
your same age that are going
yeah you know i think i'd like to be a
wife and stay at home and raise kids and
have the two or three kids and
you know all that sort of stuff but he
has to be smarter than me he's got to be
you know he's got to make a lot more
money than me does he have to be tall
um no same height as you or taller
same height or taller i guess because
that's not as important
as very much fitter okay
so you're basically looking for the top
10 odd percent of what's going to be on
the available
inventory right because as you found
society has feminized men
they're not particularly interested in
masculinity you know they think bending
the knee is going to
you know get them the girls see the way
all these
um uh male feminists think that women
operate is they keep putting quarters
in like the machine of placating to
women yes you're beautiful yes you're
smarter than i
am yes you can make more money than i
can and they think at the bottom of the
machine like a vagina is going to come
out and that they're going to have
strong
reliable access to sex but as you're
starting to learn you're not turned on
by these guys
[Music]
so do you have the attention of these
high value guys yet
uh no i do not
then that's what you need to work on
yeah
you gotta double down on that if you
want the studs what changes could i make
in my like immediate future well the
well the vast majority of men if you ask
them
what turns them on they're going to say
beauty queues and it's not
test holiday on the front of
cosmopolitan at 400 pounds covered in
tattoos because society wants to tell
men
this is beautiful too because really
it's not
if you go and look at what men are
looking at on
social media i mean just go to instagram
and see who's got the most popular
social media following it's always the
very attractive women they've got
they've got all
all the curves in the right places they
take care of themselves they know how to
put on makeup they're feminine
that's what guys are looking for okay so
you have to be that girl
yeah your camera's off i mean you're you
know you can turn it on if you want if
you want some feedback or if you want to
leave it off it's up to you
i mean what would you rate me bro from
my photos
hang on i gotta go back to my email when
did you send them to me was it a week
ago
i think so
um all right give me a second here i'm
not gonna put the photos up but i will
go back to them
uh
it's under the same name right hc yeah
there it is uh
yeah you got the same bunny icon is that
your pet rabbit do you have pets
uh i had that that was eight years ago
yeah um
where has it gone i have the message
sequence but i don't have the pictures
um if if i recall did you did you link
an instagram or did you send pictures i
can't remember
send pictures uh no they're not here
but if i recall you're you're asian
right
yeah okay well i've dated a lot of asian
women i find them attractive so i can
rate you
on the asian attraction scale um you're
you're pretty kind of average i mean
you're about a five or six at best if
i'm being honest
you gotta you gotta amp up the
femininity right i mean
again guys guys don't get turned on by
um
a piece of paper framed in mahogany on
the wall with letter little letters
after it because you've got a accounting
degree
lawyer's degree doctor or anything like
that
it's it's the standard stuff that you
that's always worked
throughout history and always will work
into the future
curves beauty long hair i think you've
got long hair right
uh yeah medium long and you're fairly
fit still
yeah okay you're
you look like an average asian girl
right
i mean we're not talking like lucy lou
in my view
is a beautiful asian you look kind of
like the average
university student like if you want to
attract that 200 000
a year guy you got to amp that up a
little bit
okay because that's what they're looking
for i mean they will be spoiled for
choice i mean you might get their
attention at an event on a dating
app or something like that but if the
lucy liu asian girl shows up on their
app
or at the next event they're they're
gonna get
his undivided attention over you because
that's just the reality of the sexual
marketplace right women are always gonna
be beauty objects
beauty objects to men some women try to
skirt that they try to convince
themselves otherwise they try to say
well
if i also make a hundred thousand
dollars a year and if i also have a
degree and if i also have a bmw and if i
also have my own house then i will also
find a good guy that will
wife me up and you will you will find a
good guy that will wife you up
but you're not going to get the tingles
right
you're not going to look at him as your
best choice even if he's smart even if
he makes good money
you're just going to look at him as well
i had to settle and unfortunately that's
what
drives most relationships today yeah
yeah does that make sense yeah
you gotta you got a lot of runway ahead
of your kit so
just i mean yeah the school stuff
matters i get it it's probably
really important your family but at the
end of the day if the end goal is
finding a good guy and having kids and
doing what you're supposed to do on this
planet which is to reproduce um
the beauty queues are what's gonna
matter the most to guys
all right yeah okay thank you all right
we'll see you later
bye bye
you